bonjour laurent robin c'est un merci de
répondre à nos questions l'appel à la
grève des personnels de santé et ils
suivis aujourd'hui
alors il ya une mobilisation qui est
fait dans toutes les régions de france
où il ya une mobilisation mobilisés sur
un peu plus réduite
lle je pense à l'état de fatigue de nos
collègues et aux non réponse de l'état
mais en tout cas on a tous essayé de
nous dit elle était présent à robert
debré pour soutenir le mouvement de gap
on l'a vu également avec estelle farges
il ya le secteur médico-social qui
manifestent aujourd'hui est ce que c'est
le grand oublié du ségur de la santé on
a vu que justement il n'avait pas touché
la prime de 183 euros et que pour eux il
n'y avait pas eu d'augmentation de
salaires donc c'est vrai que c'est une
injustice et on soutient canton
collectif leur mouvement et on leur
apportera de l'aide si besoin
quel est le quotidien des salariés du
secteur médico social mais pas seulement
votre quotidien aussi à vous en tant
qu'infirmier en cette période de
pandémie
en fait si vous voulez il n'y a pas eu
de changement particulier l'hôpital
avant la crise était déjà sur très tendu
où on arrivait pas a déjà travaillé le
monde dans de bonnes conditions
on rajoute à ça le coc vide et on arrive
finalement pas à faire nos soins de
qualité à pouvoir échanger avec nos
patients et a effectué une omission
comme on le souhaiterait en fait donc
finalement même avec le ségur de la
santé les lits ne cesse de fermer il ya
des projets de grands hôpitaux qui vont
être créées qui vont réduire encore des
lits pour favoriser en fait ce qui est
ambulatoire donc il y aura plus de place
forcément pour des patients qui vont
aller aux urgences qui vont devoir être
hospitalisée on n'aura pas de casse dans
les étages pour les prendre et du coup
ils vont encore rester vingt-quatre à
quarante-huit heures voire plus sur un
brancard pour
avant d'être hospitalisée en fait donc
vous êtes en train de dire qu'il n'y a
pas eu d'amélioration depuis le ségur de
la santé oms juillet dernier y'a aucune
amélioration parce qu'on continue
justement de perm et délits on continue
à nous dire l'hôpital va mieux etc
mais non il ya toujours des lits qui lui
manque des lits qui ferment on a un
personnel qui fuit l'hôpital public donc
il faut qu'ils se posent la question
c'est pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi elle
tous nos collègues pas pourquoi on a des
intérimaires qui reviennent qui ont
travaillé dans les services
parce que le salaire derrière et
beaucoup mieux et ils peuvent choisir
leurs jours et c'est nous beaucoup de
politiques laurent robin style il ya
beaucoup de politiques de droite comme
de gauche qui condamne la bureaucratie
du secteur hospitalier
dd structure technocratique notamment
les ars est ce que vous comprenez
cela est ce que vous dénoncez également
la surcouche administrative qui se
creuserait peut-être le monde de
l'hôpital
en fait on n'a pas l'impression que nous
on soit entendu en fait que les
paramédicaux puisse intervenir dans des
instances qui sont plus hautes et qu'on
puisse dire ça ne va pas créer des
projets avec la rs ou créer des projets
avec deux directions
mais j'ai l'impression en fait que du
coup on est on est soignant on aide
soignant on est actionnaire on n'a pas
le droit forcément de parler et on n'a
pas le droit de dire les choses
alors que moi je serais ouvert justement
à construire des projets avec les
hôpitaux et pouvoir avancer au mieux
parce que enfin ça permet d'avancer sur
nos professions et d'avancer pour une
meilleure qualité de soin pour nos
patients en faites vous
vous manifestez en tous les cas
aujourd'hui il ya eu un appel à la grève
et à une manifestation également du
monde médico-social comment concilier
revendications et impératifs
professionnels liés à la crise sanitaire
alors après c'est sur nos temps de repos
on effectue là aujourd'hui j'ai d'un
repos donc je suis allé à robert debré
si j'avais dû travailler j'aurais
travaillé j'aurais pas fait autrement
mais là j'ai profité de mon repos pour y
aller mais il ya beaucoup de mes
collègues qui étaient en train de
travailler et qui était sur le front
avec des patients pour travailler et
continuer le soin en fait et qu'est ce
que vous attendez ce soir des
déclarations d'olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé je pense qu'olivier
ferrand ne touchera pas un mot de ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui j'ai des
collègues qui ont été reçus au niveau du
ministère et y'a rien qui a été avancé
donc je pense que ce soir on va rester
encore un peu dans une langue de bois où
on va dire merci les soignants bravo je
vous félicite
merci beaucoup de travail mais on va
rien faire
merci laurent bastin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le vice-président du collectif intérieur
agences et infirmiers à l'hôpital robert
debré